hi everyone thank you all for coming I
know it's been a long day of talks so I
appreciate you making it to the 4:31
today we're gonna be talking about how
to build an AI powered pet detector
specifically inside a Visual Studio code
so we're gonna be using a few different
technologies in addition to Visual
Studio code like tensorflow
of course and Azure machine learning and
you already got a bit of an introduction
but just to reintroduce myself so I'm a
program manager at Microsoft working
specifically on AI tooling for Python so
if you've ever had an experience with
Python and Microsoft that has made you
sad let me know and I'll try to fix it
and there's my Twitter and my email all
my co-workers have more followers than
me so if you wanted to give me a favor
I'll show this at the end as well so
today we're gonna be talking about how
we classify dogs and cats so as humans
we've learned throughout our years what
a Golden Retriever looks like versus a
pug before machines we have to try to
teach them that and it might be easy
with some examples like that a pug and a
Golden Retriever they look completely
different but for instance a Malibu and
a Siberian Husky or a whippet and a
greyhound they can look pretty similar
so we'll have to see how accurate we can
get this model to be able to distinguish
between similar types of breeds and to
do this we're gonna be using a technique
called deep learning and at a high level
you could kind of think about deep
learning as this black box and we know
with the inputs we know we're gonna give
it this picture is my dog Mowgli he's
cute and we'll get back out some outputs
so some predictions about in this
example it's dog or cat or something
else but the model we're building we're
actually be saying breeds he's a mutt so
it wouldn't work well for him but in
theory so this differs a bit this sort
of black box approach differs a bit than
traditional machine machine learning you
might have seen where we can better
understand the exact features that are
playing a role in our model so for
instance if you're doing traditional
machine learning
and you're trying to create a model for
popular travel destinations you might
think an important feature there could
be climate or temperature in those
locations but with deep learning you
don't have as much of that knowledge and
there's a ton of cool research that's
going in to try to understand that and
try to reduce the biases that can
introduce there and things like that but
for novices or an immediate you don't
have to where you as much about those
things but so in traditional machine
learning you'll be spending a bunch of
time doing manual feature extraction so
this is like I said figuring out how
important things like temperature are
and cleaning your data and that can take
a ton of time and it also is valuable to
have some domain expertise there so if
you're super well-versed in global
climates it'll might be easier for you
to create a weather based model there's
someone who knows nothing about that
and then as well you'll be trying out
different classification algorithms and
initially if you're just getting started
with machine learning you might just end
up trying a bunch and seeing whichever
works out best and then as you move
forward and you're learning you might be
able to start to determine the
commonalities there which model might
work best for a certain data set if it's
numeric versus images etc but in the end
your result is the same you get a
prediction on whether or not it's a cat
or a dog or something else now with deep
learning we'll have a neural network
approach wherein we don't know exactly
what's going on in this feature learning
but the machine is actually learning on
its own which aspects of the images are
most important so often this comes down
to the curves in the image or color
profiles etc but like I said in the end
you get that end result of a prediction
and depending on what your problem looks
like either of these approaches might
get used better accuracies for image
problems like we're dealing with today
deep learning
austan results in better accuracies but
if you're doing no financial modeling
and things like that traditional machine
learning can often be sufficient so
within deep learning there's a ton of
different networks you can use today
we're going to be looking at what's
called a come loose
neural network this is a super super
popular Network for specifically image
recognition tasks and it looks kind of
like this there's a lot of animations in
this slide so you start off by breaking
down the image into RGB channels and
then from there you'll apply some
transformations to start to figure out
the model will start to figure out the
sort of edges and what where the curves
are in each image etc and then from
there and this is all at a high level
but from there you'll do some pooling
and the pooling helps us reduce the
amount of data we have to do computation
over so deep learning is a super super
computationally expensive task so unless
you have a very high corporate card
spending limit you want to do some pool
in here and then in the end we'll get
our fully connected network that can
make our predictions so to look back at
the whole end-to-end machine learning
workflow these past few slides have been
focusing on sort of the training aspect
but there's a ton of steps before and
after that namely at the beginning we're
gonna be doing some data exploration so
this is where I will get familiar with
the data sets we're working with so in
this case we're just working with one
data set but often if you're doing this
in your work or your hobby you're gonna
be pulling from a bunch of different
data sources and so you want to get
familiar with all of that data see if
you need to do any clean so there might
be a column that could be really useful
like age but maybe half the values are
missing for a bunch of the rows so
you'll have to do some work there guys
generalize them or fill in those missing
values etc so often a bunch of time gets
spent in this data exploration phase
just trying to understand and clean your
data because data is really the heart of
both machine beep learning but once
you've done that you can get into the
training step and we could break the
training down into three main pieces
your training script so this is what
algorithm you're gonna be applying as
well as the compute so if you're working
with a small data set you might be able
to run it locally and a traditional
machine learning algorithm you could
maybe do it quickly on your own machine
but when you get to big scale
data you might need custer computing
something like spark or just a multiple
GPU cluster or just a really powerful vm
in the cloud so this can be both local
and remote and then you may find you
know after you've created your training
script on one pass on your compute
you're satisfied with the accuracy and
you can move forward
topper analyzing it but oftentimes you
might want to do some additional tuning
and that's what we'll be walking through
today but once you've gotten a model
you're satisfied with and you're happy
with the accuracies you're seeing you
can get into product sizing that model
so this is when you're gonna be maybe
turning what you might start off with as
a jupiter notebook into a python module
and deploying that model to the cloud
and once you have a model deployed in
the cloud and in this case we're gonna
be deploying it as a web service this
could also be local but anywhere
publicly accessible you can submit your
test images from your test application
and start to see predictions come
through and then continue to scale this
out depending on whatever your scenario
requires so in this case we'll be
creating a web service and in the end
we'll be able to submit a picture of a
dog from our test application to this
web service and receive back read
predictions so let's start off and look
at the data we're going to be working
with so the data set we're using is this
oxford pet data set this is a super
populated data set it's fun to work with
because you just get to look at pictures
of dogs and who doesn't like that
and it's got a little 37 categories of
pet breeds it's a pretty well labeled
data set and it's got a few hundred ish
images it varies a bit by breed inside
of each or for each breed I'll send give
you the link to the slides after so
don't worry too much about copying down
these links for anything and I also
wanted to point you folks to this as
your open data sets if you're getting
started with machine learning and want
to try out different types of data this
is a resource we're investing on the
Microsoft side to publish an open-source
data sets for people to learn from and
try out different machine learning
techniques on so encourage you to check
it out there's
only a few right now we're continuing to
invest it and the more people who go
there the more things we'll publish
which makes me happy and it's all about
me so when were exploring our data
there's a ton of great tools we can use
today we're gonna be using Jupiter
notebooks if you haven't heard of them
yet we'll go through and show you one in
more detail so you'll start to get
familiar with them but these are super
useful for easy setup and quick
experimentation so you can try things
out in a very visual manner you can add
in text alongside it so you can remember
what you were doing and trace back
through your experimentation workflow
and specifically we just announced last
month
Jupiter support inside of es code this
is really really awesome we basically
are bringing the power of es code so
things like sophisticated
auto-completion
debugging etc to the world of notebooks
and it comes with a bunch of goodness
like the remote development ability to
convert to a Python script etc rather
than talk about it I'm gonna show you an
example of what this looks like inside a
Visual Studio code so this is a Jupiter
notebook that I have to train my model
using tensorflow and python and this is
all inside of Visual Studio so we can
see we can have our classic Jupiter
commands like restarting the kernel
interrupting running all ourselves etc
and we also have a bunch of additional
features on top of this such as a
variable Explorer up here right now I'm
not running anything but once I do you
can see the active variables and explore
any data frames filter them etc and one
really cool thing about this is like I
said deep learning can be pretty compute
intensive so I'm actually not running
this on my local machine it's running if
you see this little SSH down here I'm
running on a remote machine in Azure
that's GPU enabled so it's a really
powerful machine expensive and can give
me a lot more power than my
machine but I can sell access vs code in
the same way I'm used to so we can start
off by just exploring this data set with
just with the simple LS and seeing what
our folder structure looks like so we
can see here the 37 different species
names and inside of those are each of
the sets of images and to see what that
looks like visually we have a planning
function over here but so yeah we have
our 37 images or 37 folders of images
and now we can actually get into the
training step of things so like I said
we have around 200 images for each
category which may seem like a lot but
for something like deep learning and
that's not really a sufficient amount of
data and we'd likely end up with a poor
model either over it either being over
specified or too inaccurate so we're
actually going to be using a technique
called transfer learning and what we're
doing is taking a publicly available
model called the mobile net module which
has been trained on thousands of images
but these are all just general images
things like cars people etc just general
objects but with transfer learning we're
gonna be retraining that last layer of
our network specific to the 37 Pat
categories that we saw earlier so I've
had this running on my machine before so
we can see it took around 25 seconds and
to do ignoring all the warnings we were
able to get an accuracy of around 80
percent so this is super impressive
because if you look back just seven
years ago when this dataset was first
released the best researchers with
unlimited compute time could only get to
around 59 percent accuracy so it's
really impressive how much this field
has advanced in just seven years so in
26 seconds we were able to get to 80%
accuracy but I think we can do a bit
better than that by exploring our hyper
parameters so hyper parameters are
values you can set with your model
ahead of time and we're gonna be looking
specifically at the learning rate you
can think of the learning rate as sort
of the size of a staff you will are
going to take with each training
iteration you do and to do this we're
gonna be trying out a bunch of random
values so if you look here we say that
we're gonna be trying uniform values
between these two negative 15 negative 3
and we're gonna be doing 20 runs of this
four at a time and the way we're gonna
be doing that is by using Azure machine
learning service
so I basically spun up a four node
cluster in Azure and it's GPU machine's
powerful machines that and for each of
those machines we're gonna feed them a
training job and a different learning
rate and then as we go through all of
those runs as your machine learning is
going to keep track of which one of
those is seeing the best accuracy so all
I have to do is go to feed at the same
training script set up a few things and
it'll go ahead and figure out the best
learning rate for me and of course I
could do you know more total runs to try
to find a better accuracy etc and I can
show you what this looks like when it's
running so this is what Azure machine
learning looks like in the azure portal
and this is one of the runs I did
recently and as this goes better but you
can see a visualization
of all of our different runs so these
are the validation accuracies for each
of the different learning rates we've
tried out so that's a visual cue and you
can also see a few of these stopped
short and the reason those stopped short
is because we added this smart thing
here called a bandit policy and we say
that the slack factor is 0.15 and what
that means is if we're seeing a run is
more than 15% away from what our current
best accuracy is we're gonna go ahead
and stop that early so we can free up
that compute resource to try out a new
learning rate that might get us a better
accuracy because it's probably not worth
weight wasting the compute time on
something that likely isn't going to
turn into our best accuracy so this
takes around 30 minutes to run so rather
than doing that I'm actually gonna
use an existing run I've done of this so
I've read it what's called register
that's with the Azure machine learning
service and I can click to see the
details of this run in the azure portal
but so this was one I did last week I
think and we can see we got an accuracy
of around 90% and I've registered this
with the Azure machine learning service
which means that me or anyone on my team
has access to this can create images
from that model or deploy a web service
from that model all from within this
portal view or from within visual studio
code that's a high-level view of how we
can get an initial model inside a visual
studio code but I know we went through a
lot so let's walk back through some
slides about what we just did so that
was the training step in the data
exploration of our workflow and like I
said we were doing some deep learning
with small datasets and my nature deep
learning is gonna retire require a ton
of compute and a ton of time but since
you know we only had a small amount of
data it's not really gonna be enough and
there's a couple of solutions we could
do here you know we could try to get
more data so though that'd be my dream
job to just go around taking photos of
dogs probably not realistic in this case
so instead we're gonna use transfer
learning and transfer learning allows us
to use a pre trained model but someone
else spent the time and resources to
train and retrain it specific to our
data set so this can be super powerful
to get really accurate models with that
smaller amount of data and after we got
the initial model using transfer
learning so that was when we got to
around 80% we did some hyper parameter
tuning and the way we did that hyper
parameter to name was with the a Azure
machine learning service and the Azure
machine learning service one does what
we showed which was making it easy to do
hyper parameter tuning by distributing
our work for us so it was able to take
what we would normally have to run on
one machine and spread it across four or
however many nodes you want to pay for
super easily but it also
managers are your compute for you so for
instance it will Auto scale down your
cluster so obviously I don't want to be
paying for four GPUs all the time so
it'll auto terminate if it's not seeing
any activity or scale down and it also
one useful thing I love a lot is their
automated machine learning so this
essentially lets you point a ml at a
data set and it'll go ahead and try out
a bunch of different common models like
regression or a booster tree etc over
your data and then tell you which one
gets the best accuracy so this is
similar to what we did with learning
rates and hyper parameters but even more
simple and straightforward and you can
even just do it with a click through no
code experience but yeah so AML offers
sort of an NN suite of things around
your machine learning lifecycle so I
encourage you to try it both if you're
in an enterprise scenario where you need
a lot of ML ops and things like that as
well as if you're starting out and want
to try out a more visual interface or
automated machine learning they have ton
of resources for that as well so now
that we have this model and we're fairly
satisfied with it often the next step is
going to be operationalizing it so right
now all we have is this jupiter notebook
and like we saw it's super useful if you
know if i wanted to show you all in a
presentation or show a co-worker that
jupiter notebook that has all the text
has the visualizations right there
inline is really easy to present or tell
a story around your work but if we want
to productize this and make it reusable
we might want to build a Python module
and visual studio code has a couple
helpful things to do this so we have
this button up here that says convert to
Python script so when we click this we
will essentially take that notebook we
just saw and create a Python file that
looks like this and this will have cells
in line that will allow you to run all
of the same code you just saw in your
notebook but we've taken the markdown
and converted it to Python common
and broken things up into individual
cells and so this is all the same code
we've seen but just as a Python module
or Python file and here we can get all
of the good refactoring and goodness
that you you expect NBS code so for
instance we could extract a method from
this and it would automatically pull out
a function here or we could you know
rename symbols etc so we built this
experience because we saw a lot of folks
we saw a lot of data scientists who
would put their jupiter notebooks side
by side with our editor and just copy
paste code in between the two which is
super needless effort that we can do
very easily and so rather than
refactoring this all in front of you I
can show you what this would look like
so we have all of our imports move to
the top we've created a few different
functions and we have this reusable so
for instance that cell that we have that
did our transfer learning now we've
created a function from it that we can
call repeatedly same thing with our
hyper parameter tuning and so now we
have this reusable module that's super
useful for more repeatable scenarios and
once we have this completed module we
can see here we also have this
interactive window experience and BS
code so what I just showed you as a
jupiter notebook converted into a python
module and normally you'd see these
little code lenses here where you can
run the cell and it would pull out side
by side this interactive window which
gives you those same visualizations you
were seeing in line with jupiter side by
side with your code and this you can do
things like debugging with as well or
one thing i like to use a lot is yes i'm
sure so that basically i can click a
button and it generates a link that i
can send to a coworker colleague and
they can then view the same visual
studio code window as me and either we
can pair program or pair debug etc and
this is supported with the same
remote capabilities you were seeing as
well and you could always move back from
this interactive window you could export
that out to a Jupiter notebook as well
and it also has the variable explorer
and data viewer we are seeing so now
that we've got this python module and we
have our model ready we can go ahead and
deploy so since I already am using Azure
machine learning and I've registered
that model
I've actually installed a Visual Studio
code extension or Azure machine learning
and um but if this doesn't load so
essentially you would see all the
machine learning workspaces along side
of your vs code code and from there we
could just right click on our model so
we registered the model as just K camp
because that's my alias and I can just
right click and point it at just my
environment configuration so we have
just a couple things and this makes sure
that when we deploy our model it will
run with the exact same environment
configuration we expect and that we've
tested with as well as our scoring
script so the scoring script is what's
going to run when an image gets sent to
our model alright and actually a JSON
formative image gets sent to our model
and it all essentially run some
tensorflow code to score it and send
back the predictions and all I need to
do is feed AML those two files and it'll
automatically deploy a containerized
version of our model and provide you a
super-easy URL that you can then access
for testing purposes and one thing I've
also done is use the vs code remote as I
mentioned we're doing it to a data
science virtual machine right now but in
theory you could also SSH to your
production deployment and run some tasks
in that environment to make sure all of
your vitamin configurations
are running properly before you fully
deploy something or make it publicly
available and so it takes around eight
or so minutes to deploy but I've already
got a deployed version of this model up
here so I can this is the run cell that
we weren't seen earlier because the
Wi-Fi struggling for me it may not come
up with the thing so this may be fairly
anticlimactic there better Wi-Fi I
should be on you would think our
corporate Wi-Fi wouldn't work we love
upgrades okay well when this when and if
this recognizes you will see that we
have this really cute image of a Samoyed
smiley pup and we send it to our web
service and we get that predictions and
they're super accurate obviously cuz I'm
demoing it's you it's amazing
[Laughter]
okay trust me uh well I'll send you the
links to the closet or you so you can
deploy your home web service and try it
out on your own um but let's just
pretend like everything worked and I'll
go back once we're done with the slides
to see if it's reconnected and being
nice to me but okay so this is what it
would have looks like add the Wi-Fi
where we have all of our Azure machine
learning resources right here so I have
my models and I could just this is where
I'd right click and hit deploy and
everything would be great and so I can
just easily deploy a web service right
from within BS code and you can also
submit experiments so what we are doing
earlier when I showed you that view the
pretty graph of all of our runs that's
an experiment and Azure machine learning
so we could have also submitted that
directly from the vs code extension as
well as manage things view things etc
all that you'd expect so to review what
we've done today I searched it was very
satisfied with it so we're able to
explore data and train a model within
using Jupiter within vs code and then
from there we use Azure machine learning
to tune that model so we had the model
that we just ran on the D SVM to get
eighty percent accuracy and then we
could figure out our hyper parameters
tried out a bunch of different learning
rates to figure out which learning rate
was the best to further tune our model
then we got up to ninety percent
accuracy and then we took that notebook
that sort of experimental artifact and
turned it into a reusable Python module
using some of those BS code refactoring
capabilities to just directly convert
the IP ymb
into a dot PI file and extract some
modules clean up our code reorder our
imports etc and then from there we
deployed a web service and then tested
it and saw that we got great results
so for you folks what's next you could
build your own pet detector so this is
the github repository and try out the vs
code Jupiter support today so this is a
super easy way to get started with
Jupiter nvs code all you need is the
python extension so if you have use code
you go to little extensions tab and
install the Python extension and it'll
automatically handle the Jupiter
installation etc so Justine the Python
extensions Microsoft one straightforward
and it's all explained at that link and
then a few additional resources so the
slides are up at that link the github is
the same link that you just saw some of
these are also the same links but
they're good links and then we also are
outside for the next three days our
booth is like literally right in front
of this door so you can come talks to us
we are a resource as well or hit me up
on email or Twitter or yeah and I'll be
around for questions as well and oh cool
there's videos of me doing this
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks very much is villa's code running
like its own version of jupiter on the
back end or is it using your like local
download okay to do it so like if
jupiter updates its version and there's
a bunch of new features do you have to
go get a new version of vs code or will
that automatically load in its using
like your back-end installation also
have support for yeah so we use your
local jupiter installation and then we
also have some support for connecting to
a remote jupiter servers as well let's
just kind of bring your own jupiter
all right cool well like I said well
I'll be around all week thank you all